[音楽]
the
持ってを張っててみたユーチューバー
チーム初の練習階でございます
有害この
まとまりのなさ
比較行ってきた人間ばっかりなのでまだ
持ってたさんにその生活の運動してないと
思うので今日はちょっと
ともやんとか別ですけどね
ウェズリー寝るちょっとどんな感じなん
だろみたいな体は動かせたらいいのかなと
思っています
すごい
わー itano
コーンというか前週階でございますはい
よろしい待っていません
ためしましょうか営巣からあって皆さん
どれくらい運動してます
を千金のを
[音楽]
ブーブー
se ファー
しsan
いうかも始めた人になってください
パープル維持を使っています
ああそれでいいの動画ですかはいん
gretsch
言わなかっ
ana
ん
[音楽]
えええええん
ん
me
wh
b 7 aa
amaran
dec 4
のmeはぁぁ
ええええええ
ええええええされません
ameni
[音楽]
me
def
[音楽]
wh
為替はれる
や客来
me
[音楽]
ええええええ
ん
4 noneこれ
[拍手]
参加人数
富士山ねこれ人数が少ないかな
です泰明シュートやりますか
然と消えます
[音楽]
針生さん負傷者皆さん瞬きしてツアー
俺らまずしてるだけです
me
tan
tanme
me
ん
tana
me
wh
ええええええ
meああああああ
marbee
[拍手]
ああああああdeeああああああああ
me
これん
ああああああ
re
[音楽]
まずは a
me
rar
ええええええええええ
uhmeああああああ
ああああああ
ん
[音楽]
ああああああme
wh
ああああああ
ええええええ
ええええええ持っています
[音楽]
ていますええええええいい
rar マッハこの頃
ああああああ
ああああああああワンワンワンワンワン
ワンワンワンワンん
ええええええん
ええええええええええええ
[音楽]
ええええええ
はぁ
たません
eo
ああああああem ん
emん
wh
ああああああ
car
[音楽]
あああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
wh
いいいい
[音楽]
ています
ええええええ
[音楽]
ん
うまいん
ああああああ
[音楽]
meええええええ
ああああああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
me
ええええええme
[音楽]
[拍手]
しています練習グっていうのはやばいくん
もう
さあ皆さん当日までよろしくねサー
本当は解散
本ブログこんなに弾頭来週開くような持っ
てとリターンでお願いしまーす
動くんですね
hard to do
んだけどスマですなんかがわかんないけど
できるだけとみんな忙しいと思うけど
l 型の2種類を設定
途中でもっ
me
振動で頑張りましょうああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
voodoo別れん
どうでした今でも8月30が本番だから a
あと2ヶ月くらいありますけどもはいどう
だったん
ブーブー練習を
通りゃこのハイレベルなティックル
ちょっとレベル高い行くうわー
しよこれっ
パッチ3探訪連続姫と裏やだけですや心
そうですかあさんどっかあと2ヶ月という
ことで
生活でついてますけどいやもう
素晴らしい一戦だった
[音楽]
客さんもいらっしゃいますねやはり
どんどんもチームあって
あれ僕の生え際森あったんです
岩なっちゃいますよね
と年でては明かさなかった
あっ秘密の練習ですよ下でくださいね
いやマジでレベル
やっぱりいいよ僕もどんな強い高校じゃ
なかっのレモ remo 結構頑張って
深くやっつけたつもりだったので
女が家で作る
を4月に関してはそしてもある
なさい
29よね
じゃあ始める
入った
ブーバーたけどもバスケをやってるします
そう今回のパーツメルちゃんて僕の中の傷
に一つのでグレーゾーン
あーだし気楽器かパワーそっちか
パティニョ
パー
ソまあヌードあのー to
do
[音楽]
ブーブーなんだよわぁし麺だね
リーダーも者です
噛み合うじゃないですよなわけないなら何
ってシュートはいです顔もかっこいいじゃ
なかったので立てられないけど a
tan
[音楽]